FEMALE SPEAKER:
Hello, everybody.
Thanks for being here.
Today we are joined by Chef
Magnus Nilsson, head chef--
woo-hoo!-- of Faviken, which
is a hyper-local restaurant
in the wilds of Sweden.
It is currently ranked number 25
on the world's best restaurant
list.
He is the author of a cookbook
by the same name, "Faviken,"
as well as "The Nordic
Cookbook," which
is for sale today.
And he has appeared
on "Mind of a Chef"
on PBS and Netflix's
"Chef's Table."
I'm going to hand it over to
the man you're here to see.
Enjoy.
MAGNUS NILSSON: Thank you.
Thanks for coming, everyone.
So this is really exciting.
So I've written this book,
"The Nordic Cookbook,"
and I'm going to talk a little
bit about the Nordic food
culture in general
first, and then
continue by talking a
little bit about how
the book was put together.
One thing with the Nordic
region is that most people
don't really know what it is.
And that's one of
the reasons why
I wrote this book, actually.
And I've done-- through
these events I've
done kind of a little study.
So there's going to be
a raise of hands now.
How many people in this room
can tell the difference,
with certainty, between the
Nordic region and Scandinavia?
One down there.
Two?
And one that's doing this.
That's 2 and 1/2.
It's usually about 10%, so that
was a little bit below average,
actually.
So Scandinavia is Norway,
Sweden, and Denmark,
and nothing else.
And the Nordics is Scandinavia,
plus Finland in the east,
and a little island called Aland
in between Finland and Sweden,
and the Faroe Islands, and
Iceland, and Greenland also.
It's a huge geographical area.
You can see it all here.
And that's one of the defining
factors on Nordic culture,
and definitely also
Nordic food culture,
is that it's such a big area.
And in a big area,
naturally, you
have lots of diversity as well.
One thing with the
Nordic region also, it's
a geographical construction.
It's not a homogeneous
cultural region,
probably because it is so big.
Someone basically
sat down in an office
sometime and decided that
all of these countries here,
depending on who made war with
who, there is one region now.
But you can imagine that going
to, for example, the southeast
of Finland is going to be
quite different to Greenland,
for example.
I get-- quite often I
get the question, when
I talk about this book,
about Nordic dishes
or pan-Nordic dishes,
dishes that would
exist in the whole region.
And the thing is that
there aren't any of those.
There are no dishes
that look the same
throughout this whole region.
And one of the few things
that actually tie the regions
together is the seasons,
the fact that we have four
defined seasons.
And one of them, the
winter, is a season
where you can't harvest
anything, at least no plant
foods.
So all of these regions,
historically, you
had to produce an excess
of food in summer,
store it, prepare it some way,
and then consume it in winter.
And obviously, these days, no
one has to do that anymore.
We can import food.
And we can refrigerate.
And we can freeze.
And we can do all
kinds of things.
But it's still something that's
a defining factor in the way we
eat, and the
preferences that we have
for food in the Nordic region.
And one example of a dish that's
as close to a pan-Nordic dish
as you get, and also a
great example of a dish that
uses these things, the
defining factor that you
have to store food for
winter, is the open sandwich--
you know, a piece of
bread with toppings.
And then we don't put the
second, unnecessary slice
of bread, like you guys
do, on top, but, you know,
the open sandwich.
And the interesting
thing with that,
if you start looking
at the bread,
is that, obviously,
it's made from grains.
Grains is one of the
most convenient ways
of storing solar energy from
summer into the dark months
of the year.
It doesn't go bad.
It's very, very stable.
It has good shelf life.
And it's easy to process
into many, many things.
The bread also says quite a
lot about the circumstances
of where it's produced.
And we can start by looking
at the loaf, for example.
A loaf of bread, which
is an everyday staple
in large parts of
the world today,
is actually kind
of a luxury item.
It needs very special
circumstances to be produced
and to become an
everyday staple.
And in the Nordic
region, you'll have
loaves of bread, historically,
as the base of sandwiches
basically from a
line around Stockholm
somewhere and then
through South Sweden,
a little bit in South Norway,
and then through Denmark.
And why is this, then?
Two reasons.
One is that it's the only
parts of the Nordic region who
are truly urban, meaning that
you have enough population
density so you can
actually have bakeries.
Because if you're
going to eat slices
cut from a loaf of bread, you
want to have it pretty fresh
at least-- if not daily
fresh, at least not more
than a couple days old.
And if you think that modern
transportation hasn't really
been efficient enough to move
around foods for more than 60
or 70 or perhaps
100 years, which
is a very, very
small perspective
in historical terms.
Another thing with the
loaf is that, if you're
going to bake a loaf,
at least if you're not
using a tin for a
rye loaf, you have
to have wheat flour, high-gluten
wheat flour preferably,
because otherwise
it doesn't rise.
And wheat doesn't really grow
that much in the Nordic region.
It pretty much grows in
that same area that I just
described, the south parts
of Sweden and Denmark,
and a little bit
in southern Norway.
If you look at other parts,
like where I grew up,
there is no wheat.
So it's very difficult
to make loaves.
There is also much less people.
Today, where I
live, the population
is one person per
square kilometer,
meaning that bakeries
aren't very, very common.
There is one city
in my region, it's
the size of Denmark,
the whole region,
a sixth of the surface of
Sweden, one bakery, one city.
Because of this, people have
a completely different bread
baking tradition.
Instead of having bakeries and
bread becoming a staple, people
going out to buy their
bread on a daily basis,
everyone had their own
baking ovens instead.
And to heat the baking
oven with firewood,
it's pretty expensive because
you use a lot of firewood,
and there's also a
lot of work involved.
It takes several
days to heat it up
to a proper baking temperature.
And because of this, people
didn't bake very often.
So baking up north
was considered
more of a kind of
activity you did, maybe,
twice a year, maybe
even once a year.
And it was really only a way
of processing those grains
so that they became
more easy to eat.
So what people used to do was
to fire up the big baking oven,
like, mid-November, turn their
dried grains into flour--
predominantly barley
is what we use--
and then start by
making thin flat breads,
like two millimeters thin,
about this size, 80 centimeters
in diameter, and cook
them at really high heat,
like 800 degrees Celsius,
for half a minute.
And then you take them out
and they dry really quickly.
And when they're dry,
you can just stack them.
And you can keep them for
a very, very long time.
And they're consumed, basically,
by you break off a piece
and you put some butter
on, a slice of cheese,
and you eat it like a sandwich.
Or you can just crumble it
into cultured milk, or a broth,
or something like that.
And after they made
these dried flat breads,
they would continue doing
soft flat breads, which
is pretty much the same thing
just a little bit thicker,
and cooked at a slightly lower
temperature, because the oven
has cooled a little bit.
And that was
considered something
like a seasonal thing,
something you ate only
when you were baking, because
they don't keep very well.
These days you can
buy them all the time,
because we freeze them,
so it's kind of different.
Going on, after this, people
would continue by doing loaves.
And because the loaf--
because of the fact
that you have to eat
it fresh and people
didn't bake on a
very regular basis,
it was considered a luxury item,
instead of, like in the south,
an everyday commodity.
And because of this, like
as with many of the things
that we really find
special, we try
to make them even more special,
so people added everything that
was expensive to their loaves.
And, in this case, quite
often lots of sugar and lots
of spices.
So the further north you
go, in Scandinavia at least,
the sweeter the loaves
and the more seasoned.
You would have a hard time
finding a traditional recipe
from Denmark or South Sweden
that has any sugar or spices
at all in it, actually.
It's even-- I remember
my grandma's rye loaves
when I grew up.
They were almost, basically,
like an eggless sponge cake
with gingerbread seasoning.
It was very, very sweet.
To continue looking at
other parts of the Nordics
as well, like Norway, they have
pretty much the same flat bread
tradition as Sweden does, but
they don't have as many trees
because they have a pretty harsh
coastal climate in the north.
So they figured out more
energy efficient ways
to cook their flat breads than
firing up that big baking oven.
And quite often
in Norway we find
that the bread is cooked on a
heated flat stone or a piece
of sheet iron or
something like that,
with a fire underneath instead.
And you can continue
going on to Iceland, which
is where this is photographed.
On Iceland they don't have
any trees at all almost.
And because of this, they
don't have a tradition
of baking ovens either.
But what they do have is
thermally active areas
and volcanic areas.
And quite often you'll find,
just outside of the village
centers, if you have
a hot springs area
or something like that,
people have a little spot
where every house in the
village have their own hole
in the ground with a lid.
And you go there in the evening
with your rye bread dough
in a bucket, you put it down
in the hole, put the lid on,
and you come back in the morning
to pick your steamed loaf out.
And this is something that's
been going since forever.
And it's pretty cool that
it's still happening.
And, as far as I know, it's the
only example of steamed bread
historically found in Europe.
So this is-- that was a little
bit about the base, the bread,
the base of the sandwich.
And we can continue
looking at the toppings
as well, which is something
that perhaps is even more
about the culture and the
circumstances in the areas
where the sandwiches
are produced.
This photo here, it's taken in a
restaurant in Copenhagen called
Schonnemann, which is one of the
most traditional, Danish-style
open face sandwich restaurants.
And you can see the
sandwiches here.
They're super rich.
There are so much toppings.
You can't even pick that
sandwich up and eat it.
You have to eat it from
a plate with cutlery.
And it says quite a lot
about Denmark as a country,
historically,
being the only land
connection between the
Nordics and central Europe.
Loads of trade went
through Denmark.
And it's also a very rich
agricultural country,
lots of farming, which
really shows, I think,
in the way the
sandwiches are eaten.
Going up to where I live,
much poorer, less population
density, harsher climate.
As I said before,
the sandwich is
more likely to be a piece
of thin, crisp bread
with some butter and
cheese, and something
you probably eat
standing up, rather than
sitting down like this, with
beer and aquavit and stuff.
Same goes, for example,
with a Sami family
because they also have
a type of flat bread.
Being semi-nomadic, they don't
have access to baking ovens
but they also cooked
on flat stones
that they carried with them
when they moved around.
And they probably wouldn't even
put the topping on the sandwich
but rather have it on the side,
like eating bread and toppings
next to each other.
So this photo here is
from the Faroe Islands.
And here you can see
a very clear influence
on the bread side of
things from Denmark,
because Faroe Islands is a
self-governed part of Denmark.
They have a completely
different topping culture.
This here is called
raest and it's
quite unique to the North
Atlantic island communities,
this way of preparing meat.
Because the thing is there that,
since before modern shipping,
they didn't have access to
salt in big cheap quantities
like we've had in Europe
for a long, long time,
simply because it was
too cold to evaporate it
in salterns like you would in
Spain or Italy or something
like that, and not enough fuel
to fuel salt pans like they
did, for example, in
the British Islands.
So all the salt was imported,
which was very expensive,
and it was pretty much
only used for seasoning.
So you find that almost all of
the preservation methods that
are used are saltless.
And in almost all the
other Western cultures,
we rely heavily
on salt to induce
lactobacillus fermentation,
produce lactic acid,
and thereby
producing safe foods.
And this is something
that we see still today.
People don't think about it,
but all kinds of cheese, olives,
charcuterie pretty
much everything
that's umami, rich, and
savory relies on that salt
to actually become what it is.
And not having enough salt to
do that on the Faroe Islands,
people instead
figured out other ways
to control the microbiological
flora in their meats.
And one way is just take your
mutton when it's slaughtered,
hang it in these houses that
are called hjallur, which
are latticed, and letting
the very special climate
that you have on the Faroe
Islands work on them.
Because this is located in
the middle of the Gulf Stream,
so the climate is very
stable all around the year,
pretty much the same
temperature, same humidity
all the time.
And this, together with
other local circumstances,
produces really good
growing conditions
for certain types of
mold, for example.
And instead of just
rotting and decaying,
it actually preserves the meat.
But you have to be tuned into
those flavors, because for us,
most Westerners, the reason
we like, for example,
mature cheese or ham
or something like that,
is simply because we've been
taught through generations
that that's the
flavor of safe foods.
It's a preservation technique
that's going to not kill you,
basically.
Eating raest is like
the other way around.
Your body actually tells you
that this is going to kill you.
It smells like rotting
meat, death basically.
And even if you look at 10
other people, 10 Faroese people
standing around you, obviously
still being alive, eating
the meat, it's kind of
a conscious struggle
to put in your mouth.
It's very interesting
actually, because most often,
at least not to me,
there's no struggle
to put things in your mouth.
And if they don't top their
sandwiches with raest,
there's a good
chance that they'll
do it with pretty much the only
thing that grows on the Faroe
Islands that you can turn into
marmalade, which is rhubarb,
which is also true for Iceland.
There are no berries growing
on either Iceland or the Faroe
Islands, pretty much.
And rhubarb is really popular.
It contains a lot of vitamin
C, which traditionally was very
difficult to come by up there.
On Iceland, also being a North
Atlantic island community,
they do a lot of the same
saltless preservation
techniques that you'll find
on the Faroe Islands as well.
But they also smoke
quite a lot of meat.
And they do it in
smoke houses like this.
Iceland, as the Faroe Islands,
have very, very few trees.
And there's several
reasons for this.
One is that, obviously,
it's very remote
so there are not that many seeds
blowing around in the wind.
Another is that the
climate is harsh.
And the third, and
most important one,
is that they have
sheep everywhere that
eat all the saplings.
And sheep, they
also produce shit,
which is collected to fuel
the smoke houses, which
is pretty special.
So enough talking
about sandwiches
as a cultural marker,
even though I think it's
very, very interesting.
It says so much about
where it's eaten.
I'm also going to
talk a little bit
about how the book was
put together and why.
Initially, I wasn't very
keen on doing this book
and I was quite offended
when I was asked, actually.
Because I'm Swedish and,
as most people living
in the Nordic region, I identify
myself with the place I live,
rather than the
region as a whole.
So I'm Swedish, not Nordic.
And I thought it
was a bit strange
to take all of these
different cultures
and put them in one book, and
labeling that with something.
It was a bit like taking some
German, some Portuguese food
cultures, some Italian,
and some French
and just putting
that in one book
and calling it "The
European Cookbook."
And after awhile,
after maybe a couple
of weeks of discussions
with the publisher--
because I wanted to do a
completely different book.
I wanted to do a Swedish book.
But after a couple of weeks of
discussions with the publisher,
I realized two things.
One was that the very reason
I didn't want to do it
was why it should be done,
because most people don't know
what the region is, let alone
what the food culture looks
like.
And this is also something
that applies for people
living in the region.
So it's not just people
here in the US, for example.
Very few people
in the world know
what Nordic cooking looks like,
except for those very obvious
dishes like the herrings, and
the meatballs, and gravlax,
and stuff like that.
And the other reason was simply
that the publisher had clearly
decided that there was going
to be a Nordic cookbook
and if I didn't do it, someone
else was going to do it.
I didn't want that.
So the purpose of
this book was really
to explain what Nordic
food culture looks like.
How all of these
different food cultures
come together, but
also how they differ.
And that was kind of the whole
idea from the very beginning.
And I also wanted the book
to be a documentation of what
the food culture
looks like today.
Because it's very easy,
when writing a book
like this, that it turns
into some idealized fairytale
version of food culture, and
that's not very interesting.
And it's not very
accurate, either.
So the book contains a little
bit of historical dishes
that no one is going
to cook, I think,
perhaps 50, something like that.
But they're still important,
because they explain
something about food culture.
And they're important
for at least some people
within the region.
But the vast majority of
recipes in the book, they
are really the recipes that
are used on an everyday basis
in most Nordic homes.
And that has also
meant that there's
been quite a lot of
dishes that there
was debate around whether they
were actually Nordic or not.
And this is one of them,
which is, I just heard,
they also served in
the cafe today here.
What defines a
regional specialty
is really difficult
to decide actually.
And who is to decide that?
Who is the decider
of those things?
I think that one of the
most interesting things we
do in the research
for the book, for me,
was to figure out how all of
these dishes that have been
created over the last 20 or 30
years actually was invented,
and why they made sense
then, and why some of them
still make sense.
And the taco quiche is
an interesting example,
because it's the definition,
to me, of a regional specialty.
I'm going to try to explain why.
So the idea, the taco,
the concept of the taco,
it came to Sweden in the
late '80s, early '90s.
And it was brought by
spice companies who wanted
to sell spice mix, taco kits.
And it wasn't very--
it's not authentic.
It's like bastardized
Tex-Mex tacos,
but they became really popular.
I remember growing
up having tacos
at my house made from moose,
mints, and stuff like that.
And the interesting
thing with something
that becomes really
popular, and something
that people start
doing on a bigger scale
is that, after a while,
it becomes boring.
And when it becomes
boring is actually
when the really interesting
stuff starts to happen,
because that's when people,
they are changing things.
And that's when people start
to adapt their own preferences
into the local circumstances,
ending up with dishes like,
for example, the
taco quiche emerge
between the bastardized
Tex-Mex taco
kit and a traditional
Swedish meat pie, basically.
So what defines the
regional specialty?
We can look at different, sort
of-- we can compare two dishes
and we can look at different
critical points to them.
There is one dish called
surstromming in Sweden,
sour herring.
Has anyone heard about that?
A few people.
So the sour herring-- if
you ask a bunch of Swedes
to name one Swedish
dish, quite a few of them
are going to say sour herring,
which is kind of interesting.
The sour herring is the
world's stinkiest food.
It's not immediately
pleasurable.
Keep that in mind now.
OK.
So, if we look at
the two dishes,
produced in the region
could be a factor defining
whether something is a
regional specialty or not.
Like all of these foods
here, the store-bought salsa,
medium hot, that's definitely
produced in Sweden.
That's produced in Sweden.
And those nachos are
also produced in Sweden.
The sour herring is fished
in the Baltics, fermented
in Sweden.
So there are no
differences there.
So that's not a
defining factor anymore.
The history-- so
the taco quiche,
we know that it's been around
for 25 years or something
like that, maybe a
little bit longer.
So that's a very short time
in a historical perspective.
And most people think, maybe,
that the sour herring has been
around for a really long time.
But if we look at
what it is-- so it's
a fish fermented with salt.
And that's not very Swedish.
That's something
that's been done
all across the whole world.
It exists in almost every
food culture in some way.
What makes it unique,
though, is that it's first
fermented in a barrel, and then
it's transferred to a tin can
and left to do a second
fermentation in the tin can.
The tin can, it was invented
in the late 19th century
and popularized in the
early 20th century.
Or, sorry, it was invented in
the-- or it was popularized
in the early 20th
century, right,
meaning that the dish,
as such, it can't really
be much older than that.
So it's like 100 years, which is
also a really short perspective
in historical terms.
So that's not a
defining factor either.
And then we have
cultural importance.
With food, cultural
importance is quite easy
to measure because it's
just about how often
and how much it is consumed.
And if you take 100 Swedes and
you put them in one big row
and you ask, how many of
you guys eat sour herring,
maybe 20 are going to say yes.
And if you then
ask those 20, how
often do you eat
sour herring, I don't
think you're going to find
many that do it more than once
a year.
If you ask the same 100
Swedes, how many of you
guys eat taco quiche, it's
going to be way more than 20.
And it's quite likely they're
going to eat it way more
often than once a year.
So which is the
most Swedish dish?
And it's quite interesting,
if you go onto the internet
and start looking at how
much information there
is about certain things, because
one thing with these more
recent recipes is that all
that information on when
they were created and how they
have developed, it's there.
It's very accessible, as opposed
to the more historical recipes,
let's say those that were
invented before 1920,
because they are already
defined by someone else.
Someone has said what
they are because they've
been defined in
literature, basically,
when someone recorded
traditional recipes.
And then they
haven't changed much.
But with these more recent
dishes, you can really look.
You can see-- there's
another recipe, which
is called kladdkaka, which is
also really popular in Sweden.
It's another unique
regional specialty.
And you can follow
its development
from when it was first
published in 1970-something
up until today.
And you can see how it
changed a little bit
with the passing of time
to enhance the things we
did that we liked the most.
And you can also use that to
see how much people actually
consume and how important it
is with a popular culture.
And the three most-- or the
two most common recipe searches
on the internet from Sweden
on different Swedish dishes
is, actually, kladdkaka is the
most common one, 750,000 hits.
A population with
9.6 million people
is a lot of kladdkaka recipes.
And the second most popular one
is, actually, the taco quiche
with 175,000 hits.
That's way more than meat balls
and cabbage rolls and stuff
like that that's
perhaps considered
more Swedish in a
traditional perspective.
I started traveling
around all the Nordics
and collecting recipes,
basically interviewing people,
looking at what was
previously published,
and basically trying to
accumulate as much information
as possible.
And at the same time
that this was happening,
we also had a web-based
poll out where
people could report and then
submit recipes, and also
answer to different questions
about how they looked
on their own food
culture, which was very
interesting, because it turns
out that the way people see
their own food culture is very
different from how it actually
is.
Very few people said
that taco quiche was
a common Swedish everyday dish.
Most people come up with things
like pan-fried salted herring
and things like that, that
are definitely Swedish,
but that are eaten
very, very rarely.
The next step was
to compile an index
to start sifting through
all of these recipes,
and to create something that was
as representative as possible
for as big a part of
the region as possible.
And then they had
this index sent out
that had, like, 750
recipes in it, had it
sent out to one expert
in each region or country
to be reviewed, and
take away everything
that was superfluous, and
add things that were missing,
and correct all the spelling
errors, all those things.
When the index came back, I
started writing the material
and formatting the
recipes into something
that was relatively consistent.
And after that,
the whole material
went back out again
to those same experts.
And all of them
are ordinary people
with a very big knowledge
on their own food cultures.
There are no chefs
involved or anything.
They could review the whole
material again and send it back
with more feedback, collecting
more spelling errors,
especially in Finnish.
When that was
done, the last step
to put together the content
was to send the whole book
to a guy named
Richard Tellstrom.
And he's an associate professor
in ethnology specializing
in the meal as a
cultural marker.
And he made sure all the
things were actually correct,
all of the dates
and stuff like that.
When the content was done,
I started testing recipes.
And I tested about 400 of
the 730-something recipes
in my house, in
my normal kitchen.
And this, for
example, it's lutefisk
and all the different
condiments to lutefisk all
through the Nordic region.
Here you have some
split pea soup.
A bit of a spinach--
a few spinach dishes.
And one thing that's
really important in writing
a book like this that's aimed
to explain, not just to give
recipes, but also to
explain a cultural context,
and to explain why
things make sense,
and how they came up to
be and stuff like that,
is to try to avoid
all assumed knowledge.
And that's really
difficult, especially
when you think that you
know a lot about something.
And we had to work very,
very hard with this.
And one of the steps to try
to avoid assumed knowledge
was to send different
dishes of different recipes
out to testers.
So we had about 100 recipes
in the book that was sent out
to testers all over the world.
And it was quite fascinating
to see how much came back.
I have one example here.
So this was supposed to
be a Swedish layer cake.
And they shouldn't
look like that.
And the thing is that
this is actually--
everything that I
wrote in this recipe,
it's been perfectly executed,
exactly the way I wrote it.
The cake has been
baked the same way.
All the fillings were
made the same way.
The berries were handled
the same way and all that.
And I just forgot to
include one thing and that
made this whole recipe
kind of just not function.
I forgot to say how to assemble
it because, to me, it's
so obvious.
There's only one
way of doing it.
There's one way of
doing a layer cake.
This is another example.
This looks pretty
good, actually.
But it's wrong.
And the thing here-- this
is from an American recipe
tester-- and thing here
is that it turns out
that the round cake
tins in the US,
they are 25 millimeters
smaller in diameter
than the standard round
cake tins in Sweden.
So this cake is,
like, 50% too high.
And it's still a good
cake and all that,
but it looks nothing like
it should, basically.
And here, this is
actually a recipe
where I don't know
what happened there.
This is totally wrong.
Because I still haven't
figured out what
I did wrong when I wrote
the instructions for this.
But this was supposed
to be pickled Herring.
Anyhow, so that's
"The Nordic Cookbook,"
and thank you so
much for listening.
Are there any questions?
AUDIENCE: How do you
become a recipe tester?
MAGNUS NILSSON: You want
to become a recipe tester?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
MAGNUS NILSSON: Well, I don't
know if Peter at Phaidon
can answer that.
AUDIENCE: I also don't
know the answer to that.
MAGNUS NILSSON: I guess
that you just, maybe,
email a publishing
company and say that you
want to start testing recipes.
The thing is that there are
professional recipe testers.
And some of the recipes, because
they know exactly what to look
for, what to try to find
what's wrong, and about half
of the recipes
that we tried out,
they were tested by
professional recipe testers,
and the other half were tested
by just ordinary people who
someone found somewhere.
Any more questions?
There?
AUDIENCE: How much traveling
did you do for the book?
MALE SPEAKER: Just repeat
the question since they
don't have a mic on them.
MAGNUS NILSSON: Yeah.
So, how much traveling
did I do for the book?
The whole process of producing
the book was about three years,
and the first two years
I travelled pretty much
everywhere I could
in the Nordic region.
And I don't know how
many days or anything
like that, but a lot.
Because, as I might
have mentioned before,
there's not a single recipe
in there that's actually mine.
They've all been
collected somewhere,
from someone who
actually uses them
in their home, which is a really
important part of the book.
And also because I photographed
all of the whole book
when I was out
traveling as well.
And that's something that you
couldn't commission someone
to do that because
then you wouldn't
get all those little moments
that happen when you're out
traveling.
So, yeah, a lot of travelling.
AUDIENCE: Have any of the
recipes or ideas found
their way back into
your restaurant?
MAGNUS NILSSON: There
are definitely--
so the question was
if any of the ideas
have found their way
back into the restaurant.
Definitely.
And I think there's going to
be even more of that later,
because the thing, when you
have a creative profession,
I think what you produce is
a composite of everything
that you have with you.
And this being a very,
very large part of my,
kind of, daily routine
for the last three years,
it obviously becomes
a big part also
of what I produce
at the restaurant.
But I think there's going to
be, for several years to come,
more and more showing
through the menu.
Well, I have a really good team.
And Faviken is
not quite as small
as most people think it is,
because there are, actually,
I have 47 employees in
total and 21 of them
work in the restaurant.
And they are the people
who execute the restaurant
on a daily basis.
And people tend to think, when
chefs start, it's this one guy
and he's doing
all of this stuff.
And then it's actually quite a
big company and lots of people
that all work together to
produce the dining experience.
And I'm just a small
part of the execution,
even though I'm sort
of a bigger part
of the creative process and
the quality control process.
So alcoholic
beverages, in general,
is something you'll
find everywhere.
And people tend to
take whatever sugars
they have, historically,
and turn them into alcohol
that they can drink.
Beer in the Nordic
region is not-- we
don't have a huge beer culture.
People think that we do
because we drink a lot of beer,
and have done so for
the last 100 years.
But it's not like-- because
grains up there, it's
kind of on the margin
where grain grows.
So grain was usually used
for bread or for porridge
and things like that.
And maybe, historically,
it was more mead,
the only source of
sugar, basically,
that you had up there.
And the beer
culture has probably
come from central Europe during
the last 100 or 200 years,
something like that.
And you can see in the
whole region, as well,
the way we consume
alcohol, there
is one distinctive part
that is kind of beer.
And one that's hard
liquor, being like a belt
across Finland
and Sweden, you'll
have a bigger consumption of
hard liquor, traditionally,
mainly produced from potato
or some kind of grain.
And then Denmark and up
through the island nations
you'll have more
of a beer culture.
Thank you so much
for coming, everyone.
[APPLAUSE]